sie waren lange befreundet haben sogar
zusammen gelebt im sommerhaus der stars
doch kurz danach war alles anders die
freundschaft von laura und michael
wendler zu kennen der ex von benjamin
boyce war plötzlich beendet
und warum das ganze das wollen wir eine
der betroffenen fragen denn nun ist mir
zugeschaltet kate männern
erzählen sie uns was genau ist
vorgefallen
ja was genau möchtet ihr genau wissen
also sind ja so viele sachen halt auch
vorgefallen tatsächlich ich kann es kurz
zusammenfassen also im endeffekt war es
ja so gewesen dass wir im sommerhaus und
kränkeln dass michael auf und ich habe
noch ein zimmer detail zusammen wir
waren sehr sehr gute freundin von tag
eins also wir haben tag und nacht
zusammen dort verbracht und
normalerweise ist es ja immer dass die
formaten oft so dass man sich gut
versteht und dann kommt man halt raus
und dann merkt man okay es war halt nur
unter tv freundschaft wie dann
eigentlich nach beendigung der
dreharbeiten war sie wieder vorbei ist
weil auch habe michael war das
allerdings so dass die beiden ersten
kontakt zu mir gesucht haben auch zu
meinem ex also wir haben sehr sehr sehr
sehr guten und regelmäßigen kontakt
gefühlt ich muss auch sagen mehr als mit
allen anderen eigentlich also mit laura
und michael und mit willi herren und
jasmin haben mit denen waren wir sehr
sehr eng befreundet und dann war es halt
irgendwann so von einem auf den anderen
tag antworten bisschen anders und es
sind halt so ein paar kleinigkeiten
gewesen aber so den richtig wahren grund
konnte laura mir bis heute eigentlich
nicht sagen muss ich sagen also ich kann
nur spekulieren ich weiß auch dass
gesagt artikel als artikel der raus
gekommen ist und der jetzt auch im
endeffekt gegen ist meiner meinung nach
auch ein großer teil wohl auch feste
überzeugung bin dass ist eine
inszenierung war auch allein wegen der
reaktion von michael vision darauf
angesprochen habe
ja da muss sich einer ganz kurzen
nachhaken was für ein artikel genau ist
das was ist jetzt die geschichte mit dem
dann alles auf einmal das ende gefunden
hat extra mehr ausgehöhlt ich habe das
damals von mehreren leuten bekommen
das ist dieser artikel und was weiß
nicht ob man es erkennen kann
die überschrift lautet zerstört diese
frau ihrem liebesglück also von michael
und laura und ja der titel kam raus ich
muss
ein bisschen ist das nur selber daran
besteht dass ich es immer sehr schwierig
das jetzt ein paar sätzen
zusammenzufassen es war halt so gewesen
wir kamen aus dem sommerhaus wir hatten
super viel kontakt und im nachhinein war
es einfach so gewesen dass mich an klar
war wir haben uns eingeladen nach
florida wollten mit uns das machen wir
wollten mit uns das machen das machen
das machen und dann habe ich mich
irgendwann mit den beiden auch mal zu
dritt und zu dritt getroffen im
düsseldorfer band essen und jan-michael
hat die ganze zeit bildet und macht also
der hat quasi die ganze zeit fotos
gemacht videos gemacht fand sich auch
alles super ich fand es auch war auch
ein mega mega schöne zeit und ich muss
auch ehrlich sagen dass ich laufe ich
hätte auch weil gibt total gerne hat das
ich hatte die super lieb ich war immer
diejenige die die in schutz genommen hat
war egal was wagen bei uns in allen
seiten mit dreck beschmissen also wir
haben es wirklich komplett abgekauft von
allen seiten und bei mir war es immer so
dass ich ja ich habe mir ist es egal ob
da jemand ihn hasst oder nichtig
erklären die man kennt wenn ich jemanden
mag man stets zu der person ich habe ja
auch wirklich überall verteidigt immer
im nationalen nach diesem treffen bin
ich dann irgendwann halt nach hause
gefahren und dann plötzlich ein paar
tage später kam lisa große artikel
russland wo dann drin stand kate macht
sich an den rändern ich würde lieber
zerstören zwischen den beiden und wo ich
mir denke also erst mal fand ich nur ich
muss das erstmal nicht lustig weil ich
dachte okay die presse schreibt wieder
eine geschichte
dann habe ich michael dass bei watts
abgeschickt habe auf das gezeigt
manchmal komisch oder
also da habe ich noch nicht so da habe
ich mir noch nicht so da habe ich noch
nicht so an schlimmste gedacht und dann
hat er dann auch irgendwie so gelacht
und meinte ok ja gut aber hat dann auch
nicht so als eigentlich nur so ein
bisschen das auch so ein bisschen
lächerlich aufgefasst aber weil dann
wurden sie wiedersehe show war vom
sommerhaus da habe ich die beiden wieder
gesehen da habe ich nochmal gefragt und
das war nach der show da waren wir alle
so ein bisschen schon im zarten stimmung
da hat mir auch gesagt ja das ist halt
ja ich weiß wie es läuft etwas ja
niemals macht wo es läuft war eigentlich
eine route war es lustig und dann dachte
ich okay austragen zu müssen
und dann war es bei mir eigentlich klick
gemacht und ab dem moment war mir
eigentlich klar ich hab natürlich keine
beweise aber in dem moment war
eigentlich klar dass ich dafür benutzt
wurde um eine story zu machen warum ich
jetzt ist eigentlich gut erklären weil
ich halt ja hier gewinnt wie alt nun mal
auch diese vorliebe damals zur älteren
männern hatte ja oder fest hat aber dann
kann man natürlich dann so eine kälte
super für nehmen für so eine schlagzeile
wir waren damals aktuell das sommerhaus
lief und da hat es natürlich meiner
meinung nach super gepasst und als
sommerhaus geschichte vorbei waren da
war die story aus abbild da kann man
dann gelten wenn sorgen quasi da
brauchen wir uns da nicht beendet ist
kommen andere sachen mit denen man dann
quasi die man machen kann aber ich war
dann wahrscheinlich zu uninteressant für
die beiden und wurden aussortiert und
also ein abgespart abgekartetes spiel in
ihren augen kurze letzte frage dazu
denken sie dass es noch mal eine
versöhnung geben kann in ihren augen von
meiner seite aus nicht weil ich habe
auch ich habe auch mehrmals versucht zu
fragen was ihr problem ist ich hab ihr
nachrichten geschickt bei weshalb ich
hab's versucht anzurufen nora hat meine
nummer gelöscht hat mich bei instagram
gelöscht michael auch deswegen also die
beiden wollten mit mir keine aussprache
ich habe es den angeboten obwohl ist
obwohl ich richtig sauer war
ich wollte wenigstens von laufen der
ehrliche begründung jahr dieses dass man
einfach mal sagte zu kalt wir haben
keinen bock mehr auf sich weil punkte
führung aber sich einfach verbissen ohne
grund und jemanden zu ignorieren und
eliminieren das ist für mich halt
richtig richtig hinterhältig gewesen und
ja die beiden benutzten einfach meiner
meinung nach den menschen das haben sie
ja nicht nur bei mir gemacht das haben
sie ja schon bei ganz vielen leuten
gemacht wenn es gerade passt für eine
geile story dann wird man dafür benutzt
und wenn die story hand gelaufen
gelaufen ist dann kommt der nächste
so ist es halt einfach ne